[Applause]
I just learned this I love this about
you your middle name is jazz yeah is one
of your parents a huge into jazz and I
literally just texted my dad saying why
Jazz and he replied me like Daisy Jazz
me like Daisy Jazz that's it caveman
yeah me like Daisy Jazz texting is so C
I know but it's such a rad middle name
I've never heard that yeah my middle
sister is Kika Rose so he chose the Kea
my mom chose the and then my eldest is
Poppy Sophia oh all flowers in there I
like it I'm also I'm shooked from that
performance oh you're
so do you I mean I bet you do I the only
way that's relatable is I never seeing
something generally the same twice
especially when it comes to like blues
music are you like that in like acting
like when you do different scenes
constantly are they always slightly
different yes I think like in the world
of but also I think now having having
produced two films uh but my film which
is a different film to the one I'm here
to talk about but it's called Magpie
it's very helpful in the edit too to
have like slightly different things cuz
sometimes you're like oh yeah maybe that
works a little better in the
context yeah same thing was singing yeah
do you love producing cuz yeah now
you're producing as well yeah yeah yeah
my first love is acting yeah but it's
nice to be like let's get this done yeah
let's get it in yeah get in there I love
it well cuz not everybody I don't like
producing like even in music like I like
doing what I do and then everybody else
do but but I have a lot of music music
friends that like musicians do
everything and they're really gifted at
that that's not a talent that everybody
has it's I mean I don't do everything
I'm no I just mean like as an actor
though and also producing maybe
directing like people there are certain
people that really have that capability
I mean there are other people who are so
much better at all of the stuff but with
the film I made with my husband he
called me the engine cuz I was like
we're going to do this and this is how
we're going to do itas Engine Thomas
thas Thomas Little Engine I could I like
it I like it I have kids amazing wait
did are you good at keeping resolutions
we're still early in the year are you
are you good at making them and keeping
them I'm not right yeah well I don't
even know why I make them I'm never
going to learn Spanish fully it's just
never going to happen never going to
happen I just need to accept it I can
get by that's good though is it it's
settling it's a little bit of settling
but I think is it a tourist thing I
don't know I'm fine with average like I
mean I've been learning French for four
years me too that's another one but that
dualingo Al is so disappointed in me
yeah see dualingo changes it changes
that ow used to smile at me and now and
I go to the app he's very angry see Duo
is very pleased with me cuz I'm not
joking I'm on like day
1,400 but I'm like yeah but I can't
speak
French like I should be fluent you are
that committed I am I can't even get
through the 7 Days
streak
literally I get to like day six and
there's something self-sabotaging about
me that's just like I'm skipping a day
I'm like I don't have to do it it's like
you're I'm proud of you right now wow
you probably know enough to get by with
French yeah okay and it's the confidence
thing right yeah maybe that's what I'm
lacking are you are you when you travel
so much you do films are you adventurous
when you travel are I've become way less
adventurous I think that's age so I used
to be more adventurous in my 20s now I'm
like I might break something yeah I mean
I do films that are quite adventurous
like I recently played the first woman
to swim the channel yeah so I like was
in the Black Sea for N9 days swimming
and like the safety boat would leave and
then I'm there alone um alone and after
that I didn't swim again and then that's
terrifying to me that's actually one of
those things that they say like your
worst fear is just getting left and just
treading water in the ocean and I was
like well I knew what was in there
because it was like a contained sea so I
knew there W sharks oh then that would
have been fine but my thing is current
and like you know the scary stuff but
yeah I've become me and my husband went
on like a walk on some famous cliffs in
Ireland beautiful I couldn't do it what
I was
like so scared oh my God it does get
very windy too like yeah yeah yeah I
love that though I feel like it feels
fresh and like a brand new day I like it
anyway are you always affected by
Heights though can you do height like
are you one of those actors that says I
can do Heights and then you get to it
you are okay all of you are I'm like the
CV liar yeah I just did a film where I
play a window cleaner yeah and they said
um oh yeah this was actually something
else I was supposed to do on a mountain
that I ended up not doing so I was
learning with an amazing guy I'm like
you're pretty great that was yeah it was
fine my
KNE it hurt my knees watching yeah but I
was um I was asked if I liked Heights to
do this film and I was like love Heights
and they were like great like we're
going to put you on the side of a
building y y y I was like fantastic went
home was like oh my god what have I done
and then um a few weeks later we were
closer to the film and they were like
we're so sorry we can't actually put you
up there's Insurance problems I was like
guys I was so looking forward to that
there it's the best acting you've done
in the whole film it's like oh my God so
sad I would never do that for any amount
of money um I don't mind HS but like why
die when your life is all right um why
give it the the chance you know anyway
so now look at her new movies sometimes
I think about dying it's in theaters now
very uplifting title explain the movie
the film is not sad I'm just gonna say
that um the film follows a woman called
Fran who I play who uh has some trouble
socially but has a very rich in her life
so has these sort of imaginings of death
not in a morbid way just in a that's
just what she thinks about yeah um and a
new guy as played by Dave uh joins the
office office and she is interested in
him and it's sort of her journey of
overcoming the difficulty she has in
connecting with people yeah absolutely I
think a lot of people relate to that
yeah maybe not think about dying all the
time but yeah that's a little intense um
but but there's this scene with actual
like real bugs crawling on you how'd
that go over um I thought I didn't mind
bugs I I have one with an answer
crawling on my hand that was fine and
there's one where I am doing a death
Tableau and I had some bugs in my hand
but I couldn't move and I was literally
oh my God I'm I'm just gagging all the
time over the over the cliff lying down
um and that was horrid but it's also
because you can't move when you're
interacting with something it's fine
yeah but then you feel helpless helpless
yeah I don't like that yeah um so so
there's not a lot of dialogue do you
enjoy that though CU like that's kind of
cool as an actor just physically in a
different way being able to interact in
a scene yeah I feel like I've never done
like the most TWY character to be honest
um but this is my least talkie uh but
the there was least talkie there was um
there was voice over the whole way
through and I was like why don't I treat
this like stage directions instead so in
my head I was very busy like I learned
all the dialogue so it was like running
all the time so I felt like I was
speaking but I wasn't um but yes very I
yeah I play a quiet person yeah you did
well with the accent thank you yeah I
that's you said it thank you so
much but you you also love to sing and I
hear that you love karaoke right yeah
what's your go-to Tony Braxton oh my
God you came out with one of the
greatest thing Tony brex and then you
said the hardest song Unbreak My Heart I
mean I haven't done that in a long time
but there was a there's a gay bar in
SoHo and they I mean they used to have
karaoke every Tuesday and I remember
thinking I've never felt like this
before in my life I did a song I was
like everyone's so nice
[Laughter]
I am incredible I'm amazing we're all
amazing um everyone's drunk exactly
everyone's like who what's going on I'm
just saying Unbreak My Heart Is a song
that most people should not attempt
that's incredible yeah you must be an
alto I'm not uh I am an outo yeah okay
yeah yeah I mean I still shouldn't
attempt it no it was just that one time
first of all karaoke you should attempt
everything so I just have to ask because
everybody's huge fan of Star Wars do you
have any kind of tease I know you can
like say too much but um uh it is
[Laughter]
happening solid
M um I know the I know the general story
yeah which is very cool it's been a
minute though since you've done
something like it's been like how long
since the last well what's crazy is time
passing it was like 11 years ago and I
got cast that's right a baby you're
still a baby says your skin you're
welcome gentics yeah yeah um yeah so
it's been and then it's been yeah quite
a few years since I've been part of the
kind of cool to jump back in the roll
like that many years later right yeah
and also strange cuz I was the baby and
now I'm like oh I'm going to go in as
like you know I like got married and
done other stuff and like I feel more
like a grownup now yeah um so I'm real
woman yeah I like it I'm excited
everybody's you have so many projects
and you said the one I want to mention
real quick you said is it Magpie Magpie
yes so you're working on and that's the
one you did with your husband yes that
is premiering at South by Southwest MCH
oh awesome very cool all the things in
the air you're floating all the things
uh let's take another break everybody
Daisy's movie Sometimes I think about
dying is it's just a fun title to say
it's in theaters now be sure to check it
[Music]
[Applause]
out thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home